surgeon simulator amateur surgeon
plaguing biowing now comes operate now
Hospital edition you recommended it I'm
about to play it let's get it started in
a hospital every day's a matter of life
and death sounded super dramatic doctor
I know you're new here but this is no
time for nice ties niceties what's your
name Doctor Who this is easy doctor Mike
and I love that doctor spelled out I
don't know if you guys notice on all my
stuff I spa not on this onebut gaping
wound very easy two minutes okay doctor
we need to make neat stitches across the
world Bam Bam god I like using the
pencil for this hundred percent let's
put the applicator tool good work doctor
he's stabilizing perhaps now I can
introduce myself properly
I'm Amy dr. stone told me you were in
charge until he returned Amy why did no
one why did no one let me know about the
newcomer being put in charge patients
lies hang on by a thread I have to wait
for an amateur to sign off on my
operating room and it's like Grey's
Anatomy episode you don't have to talk
to dr. Mike as if they weren't here
Sirona
what do you say about getting things
running doctor all right where should we
name the hospital
what about like happy and healthy
memorial that's corny that's healthy
spot yo
here you'll find a list of available
tasks such as surgeries assignments and
more okay I got to build the operating
room building different departments will
keep your hospital running and allow you
to produce the resources you need okay
like that let's build it we have a level
1 operating room installed wow that's a
nice operating room dangerous polyp
difficulty very easy ok doctor now that
we have good sanitary conditions to
operate in let's see a perform a complex
surgery I don't know how polyp is
considered a complex surgery oh but it's
in the intestines a polyp ectomy anytime
you have a term in medicine where you
have ectomy that means you're taking it
out
I've been dekhta me taking out the
appendix polyp ectomy taking out the
polyp you get what I'm saying
first we need to apply the anti septic
tool applicator which is really true
this is the first thing that we do then
we get the scalpel and then because I
have my awesome pencil I can just do a
perfect concision right there look at
that it's like I've been doing this my
whole life
take too long or make mistakes and you
lose the patient don't stop now scalpel
let's go right into this is almost like
an exploratory laparotomy but it's a
little bit deeper than this now we could
see the polyp let's laser it Oh is good
promote healing by applying gel over the
quarter eyes area now let's suture bam
bam bam look at that
good now let's close her up all we still
have times like a needle tool
Wow Wow Wow and we cleaned it up
she said my stitching needs work but a
competent job I suppose I think she's
just hating that operation was a success
I'm the man by the way this new game
that I'm addicted to I kind of gave up
on overwatch it's called apex legends if
you want me to play season 2 apex
legends because I'm nasty drop it down
below in the comments
hospital life there are three department
types for you to manage an admission
department admits patients these
indicators tell you how much cash you
have how many beds are in use tap on
medical departments to collect the cash
that accumulates here you'll be able to
manage your staff and assign them based
on their specialty thus allowing your
departments to function on another see I
have one angry surgeon here with Sirona
size the operating room will have steady
cash flow let's claim it was exciting I
got dr. ambrosia and she gives me one
percent extra money and one percent
extra time I don't know what that means
we'll need a place where patients can
recover safety is build a ward okay ward
$10,000 I have 27 thousand let's build
it right there are 23 beds oh I got
another ward
I got John the nurse I'm gonna put
my nurse in there in the recovery area
build a break room let's do it I still
don't get the need for that resource
spending should be solely for better
patient care
well Sirona I hate to be the one to tell
you this but in order to be more
productive you need to be well-rested in
order to be well-rested you need to have
some quiet time silence is golden we
need a break room for nurses for doctors
and residents well the residents are
probably not going to get access until
they start complaining and all that
stuff but you know down much resting
will take place there's those hooligans
we'll turn it into a frat house one
hooligans we have like three staff and
in my Hospital that's called that spot
we y'all get healthy yo if a science
staff member runs out of stamina
Department stop working refill their
stamina assign them to the break room or
simply put another non tired staff
member to work there okay oh my god I
can give them +50 energy by giving them
coffee here's some coffee buddy and look
my staff is already performing better
and we've got another over award this
game is the most rewards I've ever seen
any G drink recovers a hundred stamina
points instantly there should be a
little thing on the bottom but shortens
your life just a bit work is relentless
a patient has come in with a severe bone
fracture care to take a look I don't
mind taking a look
Jake 21 went on a night out he fell off
his bike riding home and broke his right
arm
ouch the scaphoid wrist bone is usually
the most commonly broken bone when
you're falling on an outstretched hand
that's the one that's more in your wrist
this the area looks like we're going
into is either an ulnar fracture or a
radial fracture I'm gonna go ahead and
guess I'll know I don't know why I'm
just where it is I don't know let's just
clean it up let's go about
clean incision ooh which worse than we
thought
yes yeah let's get the bones out of here
good work I've cleaned the fragments now
I need you to reassemble the bones look
at that now let's place the metal
support pop that's called an open
reduction internal fixation procedure or
if basically open meaning we had to cut
open the person's body in order to make
this happen an internal fixation means
that we had to put metal hardware in
there in order to make the bone stay
yeah operation successful we could've
done a little faster if I wasn't
narrating the procedure I'm trying to
teach you how to do a radial fracture or
all no fracture I didn't really pay
attention not good to say as a doctor
dr. stone judging by the hospital's
reputation the new doctor is certainly
living up to my expectations I guess he
doesn't know what I named the hospital
thank God fracture left leg your patient
has a comminuted break along the tibia
out that's the lower part the shin bone
all right let's do it we're gonna start
by cleaning yes
and by scalpels BAM
okay now that we're inside oh the tibia
doesn't look so good we got to get these
cleaned up so let's put them up there
thank you okay okay
okay I feel like I'm like a real doctor
or something this is fun good job dr.
Mike I will say this game is extremely
extremely accurate because I'm
legitimately stressed out I feel like I
have to deal with PR bosses patients
staff members their needs their training
I mean I love playing Sims back in a day
but that was stressful what I want you
to learn from this is a how complicated
is to run a hospital you have all these
things you need to constantly upgrade
equipment make choices difficult choices
not put a break room in upgrade a break
room give a staff members free coffee
don't upgrade the camp I mean I prefer
bio-ink and plague inc to this one I
just feel like it's more mischievous and
I can have more fun playing those games
this feels like work if you want to see
some more of my game playing videos
click on this playlist right here and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]